[music]
[applause]
something huge inspire you love in
theory watch carefully
[music
] men from must be
demonstrated once there are no expelled
world the model in kenya is my enemy
was immediate help from the cameras and one of
a if the circles changed where  it
sits off the bench david street photography life and if they regain tus harping and capturing net
moment in the modeler lennox lounge how
popular the mac system picturesafe in
kenya you have to have this energy sometimes
times peaches with autofocus is
currently somebody is in hat but in
front  of the camera judo gold
bring
the decision crystals the committee
[music]
[applause]